la laïcité c'est ce que nous avons
inventé en france pour régler le conflit
entre l'église et l'état
la laïcité est un remède aux tensions
entre les religions
la religion et l'état c'est devenu avec
le temps un idéal de la société
permettant au nom de la neutralité de
l'espace public de pouvoir assurer
l'exercice de ses conceptions
personnelles tant religieuse que non
religieuse sans être dérangés en quoi
que ce soit mais en même temps tout doit
se faire dans le cadre du respect de
l'ordre public et c'est l'encadrement de
toute liberté et la liberté de chacun
s'arrête là où commence celle d'autrui
la laïcité est d'abord un terme qui a
été inventé au fil du 19e siècle c'est
la brèche révolutionnaire c'est le
moment précisément où les deux sphères
la sphère religieuse et la sphère de
l'état vont progressivement s'éloigner
cet éloignement progressif tout au fil
19e siècle on l'appelle sécularisation
il s'accélère à la fin du xixème siècle
et devient laïcisation jusqu'à
finalement aboutir à la séparation
complète des deux sphères
c'est la loi de 1905 dite de séparation
de l'église et de l'état
la loi 1905 principes fondateurs de
laïcité c'est article l'article 2 on a
tort de croire ou de ne pas croire
l'état est garant de la liberté
religieuse les cultes ne sont plus
financés pur reconnu la laïcité s'exerce
par le règlement de la question
religieuse elle s'exerce également par
le règlement de la question scolaire s
exerce également dans la société tout
entière en tentant d'établir un lien
entre chacun dans le cadre du vivre
ensemble avec l'apparition des nouvelles
questions notamment la question de
l'islam dans le débat public
les centristes souhaitent que le
principe fondamental de la loi de 1905
auquel il adhère pleinement soit
maintenu dans les débats alors
concrètement cela se traduit par le
souhait de ne pas légiférer trop souvent
pour compléter ou pour amender pour
réformer comme on voudra la loi de 1905
pour eux il reste un principe
fondamental
il faut veiller à ce qu'ils soient
préservés le centre est né comme forces
partisanes comme culture politique je
dirais presque avec les grands partis du
20e siècle avec la notion de laïcité
le parti centriste est né en 1901 avec
l'axé l'alliance républicaine
démocratique la laïcité de 1905 avec loi
de séparation
dès lors les deux entités si je puis
dire la culture politique centriste et
la notion de laïcité vont voguer
ensemble l'un ne se sera pas on ne
sépare en plus de l'autre la concorde la
tempérance la modération sont
effectivement partie prenante de la
constitution du centre en france et de
son mode d'expression dans la vie
politique
la laïcité en est une d'entre elles pas
la seule
on pourrait aller voir la question
sociale par exemple mais c'est une des
notions fondatrice de ce caractère
tempérées du centre